joining us now ed o'keefe cbs news
senior white house correspondent and
political correspondent ed i've heard
this week in washington described as
bananas and then it gets more colorful
from there let's talk about the the two
bills uh for a moment there is the
bipartisan infrastructure bill and then
the bigger bill with all kinds of stuff
in it right how do you see this playing
out it looks as if that bipartisan
bridge bill that's what i like to call
it is likely going to pass by the end of
the week president will get to sign it
declare victory and both sides will be
happy because there's billions of
dollars and they're nearly a trillion
dollars to rebuild airports bridges
rail lines across the country things
that have needed to be done for the
american people for years that they
finally have been able to get an
agreement on do we hear about coming but
they have not figured out how to pass
that bigger social infrastructure plan
things that would tackle climate change
or reshape the way we take care of the
elderly and the young in this country
provide
pre-universal preschool free community
college to eligible people would
fundamentally reshape the country you
don't hear them though and this is the
weird thing yeah talking about all the
things that this bill would do instead
you hear democrats squabbling with each
other over the price and the order in
which they're going to vote on these
things and it's kind of boggling because
you know if you're going to reshape the
country the way they are talking about
you'd think they'd focus on that but
they're just fighting amongst each other
the fact that where the fact that we're
even in a conversation that could shut
down the government on friday right
maddening to me it's like you've got
your siblings in the car and the dad
saying don't let me pull this car over
to knock it you you two knock it out and
figure it out well it's like
it's like siblings and step siblings
right because you've got the democrats
fighting amongst themselves and then
you've got their their other family
they're the republicans colleagues right
but there's no turning the car around
right now all right we're headed in one
direction but speaking of the government
shutdown for the viewer at home what
does that mean for the american exactly
well if they shut down big if because
they don't want to do that but if you
know as chris's report said 800 000
people would lose their uh their
paychecks for a little while a suite of
government services would shut down
what's unclear is how this would affect
the federal response to the pandemic and
that's a big reason why members of both
parties don't want to do this it's why
you'll likely see them pass a simple
bill that says let's keep the government
up a few more weeks we'll keep fighting
over the borrowing limit and we'll sort
out amongst ourselves how to pass these
other bills forgive the analogy
democrats this week have to score a few
touchdowns have to hit a few three-point
conversions probably can only punt once
and the only punt would be on the debt
ceiling and if you don't understand what
all that means just ask nate he'll i i
don't know people have a good offense as
well exactly i like that you kept it all
within one sports metaphor
i tried
thank you ed i noticed how you looked at
nate for giving me an hour
ed good to have you in the studio great
to be here beautiful new home yeah we
like it